this week you launch your NHS Workforce
plan so you'll plan to train and keep
more staff in the NHS you've already
done interviews on it so I don't want to
spend too long dwelling on the details
but there's one question that I haven't
really seen anyone ask you 2.4 billion
pounds over five years where's that
money coming from well it's through uh
cross government through the treasury
that was part of the discussions we had
and it signaled the Prime Minister and
the Chancellor's personal support what
does this what does that mean then is it
more money to your department or you can
have to find it from NHS existing
budgets or is it borrowing what was it
coming from so this is additional money
it will be announced as a former Chief
secretary will be announced in the usual
way through fiscal events it ramps up
because obviously one of the features of
the workforce plan and it is the biggest
ever expansion in Workforce training in
the NHS it's a hugely historic moment as
we celebrate the 75th anniversary of the
NHS the Fantastic achievements of the
NHS it's a major commitment from the
government and it reflects the the prime
minister's personal commitment to the
NHS coming from an NHS family both these
parents worked in the NHS and the
chancellor has long called for a
long-term Workforce plan so reflects
their support it's 2.4 billion of
additional funding that will be
announced by the chancellor in the usual
way at the next fiscal event so that's
additional funding to the department so
I haven't heard any you know tax Rises
or spending cuts so I'm assuming this
sounds like it might be extra borrowing
100 of GDP that's the current level of
debt interest rates Rising so the cost
of service in government debt is going
up is that really responsible well it
scales up Sophie so first year obviously
you're going to have one year of people
being trained in the second year that
doubles
the policy of 2.4 billion without saying
how that money was coming from you would
be after them like a rocket it scales up
you've got to see that in terms of the
way they're doubling on medical
undergraduates works is obviously that
is cumulative because the second you've
got double the number the third year
triple so that scales up over time but
also it helps in terms of the cost of
agency the cost of Bank and other
support so it's important to our
retention in the NHS if we have more NHS
staff staying that is a cost-effective
approach so what the plan is about is
training more yes but also how do we
have better retention and also how do we
deliver that training in more efficient
ways through reform so there's three
elements to the plan not just the
increase in numbers but also the work on
training and reform the one thing that
could also help the NHS recruit and
retain staff is better pay and the
independent pay review bodies will soon
publish their recommendations about the
uplift that health workers should get
will you stick by what they recommend
well we'll take those decisions on a
cross-government basis I'm very pleased
we've now reached agreement with the
largest group within the NHS excuse me
which is the agenda for change Workforce
that's 1.3 million people within the NHS
where the government and the NHS staff
Council has reached agreement that means
those staff will get the pay-up lifts in
their pay packets this month so that
shows the progress that we are making in
terms of The Wider prb that is something
that is discussed cross-government it's
not just an issue within Health it also
affects for example teachers and the
education unions affects other
departments in government so we'll have
those discussions on a cross-government
basis but it's hugely positive that we
have reached agreement with the largest
of the health bodies the 1.3 million
covered by agenda for change it's weird
that you won't say that you'll stick to
the pay review recommendations because
this is what you said about them last
year and when you're talking about pay
there and you tweeted to say we have an
independent pay review body which the
unions campaign to set up and we will
continue to defer to that process to
ensure decisions balance the needs of
staff and The Wider economy so you'll
defer to the pay of your body when you
like what they say but you reserve the
right to ignore them when you don't I
think when I was on the show previously
you criticized me for adhering to the
full pay-per-view body because there was
a pressure to go further there was
questions in terms of because of the
change in inflation you were saying we
shouldn't just stick to the full pay for
your body we should actually go further
and indeed the government I'm putting
the differences forward so as you would
expect me to do I'm just trying to work
out why your position you're the health
secretary right you're the one who has
actually influence I'm just a low lead
TV reporter I've got no say over uh what
pay all these people get why do you say
that you should defer to the pay review
process when you like what they say and
not when you don't well the point we
discussed when this was raised last time
and you bring the quote up from last
time which is why I'm making the point
was we should also look at the wider
economic circumstance and that was the
point that you were raising with me you
know last time Sophie and that's why you
say here instead you should balance the
needs of staff and The Wider economy now
you're saying actually we just need to
look at the wider economy not the needs
of stuff
we need to do that we need to do both
and that's exactly what we have done
with the agenda for change which is why
not only did we apply the full pay
review body recommendations we actually
went further in terms of a lump sum for
start because we hugely recognize the
pressure that NHS staff have been under
from the pan they make an older
population advances in medicine enabling
more to be done we both adopted the full
pay review body but we actually went
further last time of course we need to
look at the wider pressures in terms of
inflation our commitment to halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt as well as cutting waiting times
and stopping the boat so we need to look
at these things in the round that's what
we did last time which is why we made
adjustments of course we'll take a
similar approach this time they're
expected to recommend a six percent rise
for NHS staff would that be acceptable
to you well as I say these will be
discussions that I have on behalf of the
health Workforce with the Prime Minister
the chancellor that the education
secretary will have on behalf of
teachers and other ministers will have
across government so we will have those
and we'll make announcements in due
course
um you were early
I mean it's great that you have
agreement with some people who work for
NHS and but of course Junior doctors is
outstanding they're planning their
longest ever strike later this month
Thursday the 13th to Tuesday the 18th of
July will that put lives at risk well
it's hugely concerning uh and it's
hugely grateful to those within the NHS
who have stepped up when we've had past
Junior doctor strikes who come in often
change their holiday plans to provide uh
cover the junior adopters are continuing
to demand a 35 pay rise I don't think
that is Affordable in the context of the
inflation and the other is that true
they say that they want to get around
the table and actually thrash something
out but you don't want to talk to them
do you well we have and we had three
weeks of talks not only that they asked
to bring an intermediary and a very
senior respected NHS leader Kathy McLean
who had played a pivotal role in a
previous dispute between SAS doctors and
the department the department agreed to
bring it in and out intermediary but
notwithstanding Kathy's excellent work
the discussions that we had with the
junior doctors today they have refused
to move from a 35 demand where they talk
of a additional year using 2024-25
actually they demand a 49 increase
because of that additional year so I
don't think that in the context of The
Wider economy the need to get inflation
down that is a fair demand of course
both sides need to move we are willing
to do so in good moment we have accepted
the use of the intermediary that the BMA
why don't you get around the table with
them now it seems a bit arrogant doesn't
it if you won't even talk to them now or
being consistent not just in health but
in all departments that if people
suspend the strikes then we can get them
around the table have talks at the
moment the junior doctors have walked
away from the talks we were in the
middle of discussions with them there
were a range of other factors that they
have raised with me in terms of annual
leave that is often canceled at short
notice rotors that have changed some of
the well-being issues around uh
circumstances in hospital so we're happy
to discuss those we were in the middle
of discussing some of those wider
non-pay issues is the junior doctors
sadly who walked away from the
discussions and called a further strike
now whenever she see next five pledges
was to cut NHS waiting times how's that
going oh well we're making progress on
our longest weights that's what the plan
committed to we virtually eliminated the
two-year weights last summer we
committed to reduce the 18-month weights
we cleared over 90 percent of those and
if you can trust our performance with
labor run uh the NHS in Wales we're
making much more progress so we've got a
population 18 times the size of the NHS
in Wales if you just let me finish the
population in England is 18 times the
size of that in Wales we virtually
eliminated our two-year weights in the
summer we got our 18-month weights to
down below 12 000 yet in Wales that was
30 000 for two year weight and around 70
000 for 18 month wait so we're making
much more progress than we see in labor
memorials and yet Kirsten Thomas says
that's the blueprint for a labor
government if you forgive me for coming
in
um thank you very much and the number of
people waiting for routine treatment has
risen from 7.2 million to 7.4 million I
mean most people would say that does not
look like progress most people who are
experiencing what's going on in the NHS
would not say that looks like progress
if you look at the plan that was set out
in 2022 by NHS England it always
anticipated that the bounce back from
the pandemic would mean that in terms of
the overall size of the list it may
continue to grow in fact
I haven't talked about it coming down in
March of next year now what we're doing
is fast tracking things like our
diagnostic Centers we've got 108 open uh
now we're going to have 160 open shortly
that's delivered 4 million additional
tests and scans we've got more treatment
being capacity being rolled out 43 new
and expanded surgical hubs so we're
boosting our treatment that takes time
to come on stream we're making progress
we're cutting the longest weight okay
and we're fast tracking the capacity to
bring the overall size of the waiting
list out I just want to be honest you
know looking at the five pledges that
which is unac made that he said he
wanted to be judged on and it seems like
you guys are on pretty shaky grounds you
know half inflation stop the boats cut
debt when the Prime Minister announced
them six months ago he said simply no
tricks no ambiguity we're either
delivering for you or we're not what
happens if you're not well the Prime
Minister was clear these were tough
targets that he set himself and rightly
so what most people thought they were
easy that they were low bars well you
can now see that there were tough
targets that were set and it was right
that we did so enough to take away to
list the plan is working we cleared the
longest weights that you awaits we
cleared we cleared the longest way it's
what the plan set out was the target the
longest weights we cleared the two-year
weights last summer we cleared over 90
of the 18-month weights we're now
focused on the 65 week weights that's
the next element of the plan and we're
massively accelerating the Royal layout
of our diagnostic Centers
overall Quantum down through the five
pledges around the economy but debt is
100 percent of GDP the economy grew by
0.2 percent in April inflation's far
higher than expected you know what
happens when the guy who says he's the
one to fix the economy doesn't actually
fix the economy well you see that
because we've had two 100 Year events of
course there's been huge pressures and
these are not alone to the economy in
England
issues for our economy you will
acknowledge that so you're a smart guy
you know that well we're growing the
economy we recognize the Oasis
recognized at that reasonably the
progress that has been made but of
course we've had two one in 100 Year
events those have had an impact but if
you look at the progress we're making
in-house the rolling out of national
lung cancer screening this week
now I guess you know the question was
what happens if the guy who says he
fixes the economy doesn't fix the
economy and I think I think really we
know people will start turning away from
the conservative party a poll in the
Sunday Telegraph by opinion funds you're
on course for the biggest by-election
defeat in British history mid
bedfordshire when Nadine Dorothy C and
before you say it's just one poll I
think we're going have a look at our Sky
News poll tracker which shows
unsurprisingly perhaps you know the
conservatives are still well behind
labor not much sign of that improving at
all
at what point do you start to panic well
we recognize it's tough because we've
had a pandemic we've had a war in Europe
that's had a big impact in terms of
inflation in cost of living but look at
what labor is coming for when nothing in
terms of helping on inflation they want
to add 28 billion uh to our debt that
will make the problem whereas if you
look at stopping the small boats there's
no Pro uh proposal from labor to do so
absolutely silence on that if you look
at our biggest ever expansion of the
workforce in the NHS this week that by
2.4 billion are pounds labor has no
proposals on reform in their equivalent
plan it was completely silent on the
innovations that we're bringing forward
and what we're doing is getting on in
innovating coming out of the pandemic if
I take the example of lung cancer in our
most deprived communities previously
four in five patients were diagnosed
late we've turned that on its head it's
now through our Pilots three and four
that are diagnosed early if you look at
the investment we'll make taking in
research to get the latest Innovations
into the NHS 96 million pounds we
announced on Tuesday for 93 different
institutions if you look at the work of
mental health often that's been an area
that's been neglected significant
additional funds 2.3 billion more this
year than four years ago so a huge
amount of innovation and work is going
on we will recognize there's much more
to do just finally rumors of a reshuffle
after the by-elections next month and I
just want to read you a quote in the
times if I may I think you might know
which is coming most of the cabinet the
time says is expected to emerge
unscathed although there continues to be
speculation about the futures of Steve
Barclay the health secretary and Therese
Coffey the environment secretary
don't worry of course it's always for
the prime minister to pick the the
cabinet and his team and I've worked for
three prime ministers and you can see
the progress we're making as I say if I
just take this week the lung cancer
National screening the run out of
research the progress on mental health
and the workforce plan and that's what
I'm focused on